قد يغيب عن ذلك انك قبل عشرين عاما لم
تتخيل حتى امتلاك هاتف ذكي ولم يكن يخطر
على بالك انك بنقره واحده يمكنك الاطلاع
على حياه اصدقاء وغرباء يبعدون عنك الاف
الكيلومترات فقبل عشرين عاما لم يكن هناك
ايفون او انست
جرام فيسبوك او يوتيوب او نتفليكس او
اليكسا او سيري او تشات جي بي تي او تسلا
والقائمه تطول فجميعنا يعرف ان الحياه
البشريه بعد نهضه الذكاء الاصطناعي ليست
هي كما كانت قبله
[موسيقى]
تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي على نحو متسارع في
العقدين الماضيين جراء استخدام تقنيات
ابرزها ما يعرف باسم التعليم الالي اي
قدره الالات الذكيه على تعليم نفسها عن
طريق مراجعه كميات هائله من البيانات ومن
التعليم الالي ما يوصف بالتعليم العميق
الذي صمم ليعمل مثل الشبكات العصبيه في
الدماغ البشري
ومع التعليم العميق اصبح الذكاء الاصطناعي
اقرب الى الذكاء الطبيعي اثبات يصعب
التمييز ان كان محدثك الافتراضي مثل شات
جي بي تي اله من الخوارزميات ام انسانا
سويا فهو قادر على كتابه المقالات
والابحاث والشعر واضحى مثار جدل في
الجامعات والمدارس الامريكيه التي منع
بعضها استخدامه لانه يقوم بالواجبات نيابه
عن الطلاب
[موسيقى]
وفيما يستبشر المعنيون في عده مجالات
كالصحه والصناعه والتكنولوجيا خيرا بتطوير
الذكاء الاصطناعي يخشى كثيرون في الولايات
المتحده من استيلاء الاله الذكيه على
الوظائف او من استخدامه لاختراق الخصوصيه
او لنشر معلومات مضلله او فيديوهات مزيفه
او استخدامه كاداه للمراقبه عبر برامج
التعرف على الوجه وهو امر استدعى حكومات
عده مدن امريكيه عام 2019 الى حظر استخدام
هذه التكنولوجيا
الولايات المتحده مقر اهم شركات
التكنولوجيا تفتقر الى قواعد مكثفه تحكم
كيفيه نشر الذكاء الاصطناعي الامر الذي
يرى خبراء انه سيكون الفاصله لضمان
استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل امن وهناك
ايضا من يحذر من يوم يتمكن فيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي من اخذ زمام المبادره من البشر
لكن هذا ضربا من دروب الخيال العلمي حتى
الان لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم واشنطن